la peinture c'est pour moi le meilleur
exutoire ça m'a sauvé france bédard
affirme s'être fait violer par un prêtre
en 1965 elle n'avait que 17 ans c'est
arrivé l'été alors qu'elle travaillait
dans un presbytère dans la région de
québec
j'ai passé ma main pour éteindre fermé
l'interrupteur et celle à qui marc
greipel bros puis ma proche de celui
embarqué par deux sous un pin meloche
complètement saisi loges
j'ai dit non monsieur picard non non je
veux pas légitime j'ai dit c'est un
cheminot j'ai jamais connu deux hommes
et 10 et un soir tu veux savoir c'est
quoi un homme
peu de temps après elle tombe enceinte
et donne son enfant à l'adoption
c'est la honte roxas h parce que je me
souvienne prête
il y avait une vocation à sauver je les
fais péché
donc il fallait que il fallait que lui
continue sa vie continue son salaire
certain c'est que moi je m'arrange avec
mes problèmes
c'est comme sur les victimes et on est
tous des coupables
quand on est jeune on se sent coupable
on a honte et on n'a pas peur et j'avais
souvent indigents aller au bout de tout
des années plus tard elle a quand même
poursuivi son agresseur ou criminelle
mais il est décédé quelques jours avant
le procès en 2008 france décident de
fonder une association pour venir en
aide aux victimes de prêtres
j'en entendu des centaines de victimes
j'avais trois fois plus d'hommes que de
fin 2013 ces victimes des frères de
sainte-croix viennent de remporter une
victoire
on est soulagé que ce soit maintenant
derrière nous plus de 15 millions seront
versés à 206 sommes agressés dans leur
enfance dans trois collèges dont celui
de notre dame à montréal
sébastien richard et leurs porte parole
il s'est fait agresser à trois reprises
par un prêtre à l'âge de 14 ans je me
souviens très bien qu'ils étaient très
très nettement en érection avec mais
avec mais mais mais dans son pantalon et
ça et c'est allé jusqu'à l'éjaculation
dans son corps alors et puis la fois
suivant le lycée il s'est baissé le
pantalon de m'expliquer son anatomie
ce sont des prédateurs lui se considère
comme étant une victime il n'a rien fait
de mal
il a été envoyé à un certain moment au
rwanda alors on peut manifestement
imaginer que fait des victimes là ça
fait absolument pas de doute et contenu
que sur les 206 victimes qui ont été
indemnisées dans le premier recours
collectif contre 10 et une croix à lui
seul il a fait plus d'une trentaine de
victimes
alors vous imaginez que que c'est un
homme qui manifestement
extrêmement actif sexuellement je vous
rappelle que c'est dans le fond d'un
taux d'abstention
l'agresseur présumé n'a jamais reconnu
sa culpabilité pour ses gestes
j'espère que les gens seront championnes
est encore aujourd'hui il ya des revues
cas besoin alors ce noël avocat qui a
défendu les victimes des frères de
sainte croix et ces jours ci il ne
manque pas de travail
au moment où on se parle j'ai 536
victime qui nous ont contactés dans
différents locaux ça et plus globalement
près d'une centaine d'après croyais en
avoir d'autres c'est sûr qu'un ado pour
une victime qui dit long sur neuf qui ne
dénoncent pas c'est connu
dans la majorité des cas les victimes
d'agressions vont attendre 40 50 et même
60 ans avant de dénoncer leur agresseur
avez vous encore des victimes qui
viennent cogner à votre porte
toutes les mains 1 toutes les semaines
j'en ai dans ma salle d'attendre
actuelle puis on a déjà des rendez vous
pour la sotra jeu
les évêques catholiques du canada ont
tenu à rassurer les victimes de prêtres
l'été dernier en affirmant que l'église
était de leur côté la grandeur d'une
civilisation se mesure à la place
qu'elle donne aux plus petits
l'archevêque de montréal a fait écho à
cette déclaration dans une lettre
ouverte en précisant que l'archidiocèse
irait au fond des choses
six mois plus tard nous avons tenté d'en
savoir plus on seigneur lépine a décliné
notre demande d'entrevue par le biais
d'un message écrit
soyez assurés que nous communiquerons
avec vous lorsque l'archevêché
souhaitera faire une déclaration
publique à ce sujet pour mettre
arsenault la seule solution est une
commission d' enquête pour faire la
lumière sur ces dérives du clergé
ils sont dans une ou encore dans une
dynamique je parle plus des
congrégations religieuses à ce moment-là
de négation de contestation il permet à
tout coup s'impliquent des sommes
d'argent importantes qui vont pas aux
victimes
les victimes croit aussi qu'une
commission denquête serait salutaire
je pense sincèrement qu'au québec on est
dû pour une bonne conversation et
j'emploie le mot conversation parce que
c'est certain qu'il ya des gens qui vont
devoir répondre de leurs actes
les gens ont des bons encore des frais
une commission d'enquêté mais c'est
comme ça qu'on peut creuser davantage
s'il le disait sur faisons des lumières
que les gens peuvent commencer notre
guérison commission denquête ou pas le
mal est fait et certains ont perdu la
foi
êtes vous encore croyante j'ai jamais
j'ai apostasier maintenant
[Musique]